Narrator: IN THE WORLD OF
INTERNET SCIENCE WIZARD
BRUSSPUP,
NOTHING IS QUITE WHAT IT SEEMS,
LIKE THIS RULER...
♪♪
...AND THIS KNIFE.
WE'RE ONE STEP CLOSER
TO AN INVISIBILITY CLOAK.
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE CLIPS
BECAUSE THE PHYSICS IS SO SMART.
Narrator: BRUSSPUP'S
INVISIBILITY DEVICE
CONFOUNDED
1 MILLION VIEWERS ONLINE.
BUT HOW DOES IT WORK?
NORMALLY, WE SEE THINGS
BECAUSE THEY EITHER EMIT LIGHT,
LIKE MY SMILE,
OR THEY REFLECT LIGHT,
LIKE MY SMILE.
IN THIS CASE, NEITHER OF
THESE THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
WHAT BRUSSPUP HAS DONE
IS USED A SET OF LENSES
SO THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN PLACES
HE CAN HOLD OBJECTS
SO THAT THE LIGHT REFLECTED
FROM THEM NEVER
REACHES THE CAMERA.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THE LIGHT FROM BEHIND THE OBJECT
DOES REACH THE CAMERA.
AND IT GIVES THE ILLUSION
OF THAT OBJECT
HAVING DISAPPEARED.
Narrator: SO HOW DID BRUSSPUP
PULL THIS OFF?
IN BRUSSPUP'S SETUP,
HE HAS FOUR LENSES AND A CAMERA.
Woman: THE LIGHT FROM THE
BACKGROUND ENTERS THE FIRST LENS
AND GETS FLIPPED UPSIDE DOWN.
IT'S SENT FROM THE SECOND LENS
TO THE THIRD LENS.
AND BETWEEN THE THIRD
AND FOURTH LENS,
IT'S FOCUSED DOWN ONTO A POINT
AND FLIPPED UPSIDE DOWN AGAIN.
BY THE TIME IT COMES
OUT OF THE FOURTH LENS,
IT'S NO LONGER DISTORTED.
IT LOOKS EXACTLY AS IT SHOULD DO
IF THERE WEREN'T
ANY LENSES IN BETWEEN.
THE AREA BETWEEN THE LENSES
BUT OUTSIDE THE BEAM OF LIGHT
IS KNOWN AS THE CLOAKING REGION.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE ANY LIGHT
THAT ENTERS THE LAST LENS
FROM THIS REGION
DOES NOT MAKE IT TO THE CAMERA.
AND IT'S THOSE POINTS
HE CAN PUT IN A KNIFE,
HIS HAND, A LASER.
AND THEY WILL DISAPPEAR.